moved here to Los Angeles in 95 1996 oh
yeah do you think you work harder now
than you did in 96 or is it a different
type of working at it it's a different
type of working at it like I said you
know when I first moved here you know I
had blinders on and you don't really
realize what you're getting into
you know what this means and so I you
know I worked very hard to break into
the business and I got very lucky that
happened performing at a very early age
you have to work just as hard you know
if not harder once you do get some
success I think you have to keep working
to hopefully keep that success although
this business is up and down up and down
it doesn't really seem to be anywhere in
between at least for me it kind of seems
like you have those good years and then
you have years where you don't work I
mean Conor and you have to write it out
and a lot of actors will ask what's what
what do you suggest but what's your
advice and I said the persistence is the
key don't leave you can be the last one
standing I think is what I my acting
coach said to me be the last ones
standing so you have to don't give up
because if you give up that might have
been the next day where you got that
audition that's going to change your
life so if it's who you are and don't
give up you can't as much as you want to
as much as I have many a days where I'm
like I just want to say peace out and
run and go the other way but then I
would be miserable you know because it's
Who I am
so I know we talked about this a long
time ago in 2012 I think that you'd said
that you you knew that this was a choice
you were going to make but maybe you
could revisit it for us where do you
remember the exact moment where you said
this is what I want like it's not going
to be okay if if I you know this isn't
gonna work when I get a job you know go
back to like a vocational school and try
like get a desk job or so I mean when
did you know that this was for you I
knew I knew I knew in in high school
that's what I wanted to do at a very
early age nobody was gonna tell me
differently and you know looking back I
don't think I'm not the guy to sit
behind a desk at an office not that
there's anything wrong with that it's
just not who I am I'm kind of used to
the uncertainty now in sort of the crazy
off life it is to be an actor
it's not a regular thing there's no
certainty in this business there's a
mostly uncertainty so you kind of have
to roll with that so being comfortable
with being uncomfortable exactly exactly
yeah it's being comfortable with being
uncomfortable which is pretty much all
the time and then you'll have a couple
great months where you work and you go
on location the last movie I did with
the Bulgaria for a month and a half and
got to work with Antonio Banderas and
Sir Ben Kingsley and I was amazing you
know and then you come back and it's
back to reality so it's like you know
it's a very weird weird business it
changes on a dime and that's what I love
about it you know you just never know
again
you